let's bring in Bob Costas Hall of Fame
broadcaster MLB Network host
play-by-play voice good morning Bob let
me start with the NFL what do you make
of this expansion don't don't start with
the NFL let's start with Fritzi I think
on tomorrow's show he should just open
up with this overrated list Willie Mays
Wayne Gretzky's Michael written and
Brown and then let the conversation go
where ever it's going to go once again
with the grotesquely overrated Beatles
and Bruce Springsteen and go from there
can an opinion be factually wrong yeah
yeah I mean this is this is why callers
call in people write songs and they say
suck it back row because of the comments
I have from the back row here and Fritzi
yeah frenzy leading the charge here well
I think there's no stats except for
records sold and I guess concert
attendance there's no stats when it
comes to the Beatles or Springsteen or
whatever but when it comes to sports
yeah you can argue around the edges
whether we'll Chamberlain was better
than Kareem but you at least have some
statistics to refer to you can't say
outright that either one of them is
greatly overrated I remember you did the
interview with Springsteen when he was
doing the halftime show yeah how big of
a sports fan is Springsteen huge
baseball fan but he actually said on
that occasion I don't really follow
football and he said with a laugh we've
got a record to promote and this is the
best possible place to promote it so he
said don't don't ask me any football
you've has he been to a game that you've
been at baseball yes in 1998 he brought
his then young son Evan to st. Louis on
the weekend that Sosa and McGwire were
vying they were he's close to 60 or 61
and he went down into the Cardinal
clubhouse and actually traded a
Springsteen guitar for a Mark McGwire
bat Wow and he stayed for the whole
series stayed for all three games no
that's cool yeah what do you make of an
F L expansion do they eventually you
know it can we get to the point of no
return
with the NFL I guess you could but I
don't think they've reached it the
interest is extremely high and football
is different from baseball they play a
shorter regular season the only real
difference would be I guess as I
understand it only the top division
winner in each conference would get a
bye instead of the first two but it
doesn't drastically alter the setup it's
writtens the preseason which fans like I
guess they'll throw in an extra buy week
they might push the Superbowl and this
also makes sense residents weekend the
whole thing actually makes sense both
from a business standpoint and from a
competitive standpoint I think it makes
sense they're gonna have to expand the
rosters because the wear and tear of the
system if you're going to add an extra
game and add an extra buy week but it
seems like all those necessary steps are
logical and don't really upset the
applecart all that much yeah I agree
with the president's weekend because
then that gives you that holiday that
Monday after the Super Bowl that a lot
of people take off anyway now you're
you're saying hey we acknowledge that
you can take off that day of work I'm
told they're only gonna add maybe one or
two more players to the roster when they
go to 17 game regular season schedule
I'm no expert on this but that doesn't
seem like enough to me and I think the
Players Association would have a very
strong case to argue for more why isn't
the Astros story going away because the
players I think the players are keeping
it going and adding extra fuel I'm sure
you've mentioned this before at the
height or depth of the steroid era
lots of players would privately express
their concern and eventually they push
the Players Association to recognize
that many of their own members were
victims rather than participants in PE d
use but they never said anything
publicly this was before players had
Twitter accounts and Instagram and
everything else and that adds fuel to
the fire too but I think what's really
keeping it going is how outspoken and
adamant the players themselves have been
because we in the press and baseball
officials had their say within the last
few weeks
now it's the players once spring
training has arrived and they're being
asked questions for going on their
social media accounts it's the players
now that are really keeping it going
yeah I'm trying to figure out how this
ends you know everybody wants something
out of this and I don't know what that
something is
and I I said look if you want to take
away the trophy and vacated okay fine if
I can't punish the players then I don't
want people picking up a baseball and
thrown at 95 miles an hour at them and
extracting some you know kind of revenge
but what what would be your solution
where you think that you could placate
the players and the fans affected by
this I said this the day the story broke
after the athletic had Mike fiers
information and then eventually that the
Commissioner came down with his
penalties and Jim crane fired hints and
Lou now that my suspicion was and it
turned out to be correct
that they had to grant immunity to the
players both because of existing
understandings and the basic agreement
and because they would have gotten huge
pushback from the Players Association in
any case so that was a road they didn't
want to go down but I speculated at that
time that they could very well wind up
in the same place they wound up with
steroids and peds which was that
eventually they recognized that there
was mutual interest here the Players
Association would have to agree and
they're hearing it from their members
now as when it comes to the Astros
they'd have to agree that the majority
players are victims when other players
and so in the next basic agreement I
think they're going to have to codify
penalties just like they eventually did
with steroids they've had to codify
penalties this is what happens to
players if and when they're caught doing
this kind of stuff but if I can dan I'm
going to go against the tide a little
bit when a lot of people have said fans
and from people in the press this is no
deterrent Manfred's initial ruling
destroyed current because the players
themselves weren't punished but I don't
think that makes that much sense because
they said beforehand in the memo in
September of 2017 and in their penalties
Hinch fired
Lou no suspended then fired
in Corydon eventually fell Tron although
that wasn't a commissioners decision but
the Mets decided what's clear is this
there's no way that players even if they
want to do it again if some players
somewhere wants to do it again there's
no way that coaches and managers
wouldn't know about it
hinge do about it all right no manager
is going to say you know what only way
the risk/reward it's worth it to destroy
or at least significantly derail my
entire career and look the other way
while these players are cheating so I
think actually if you think about the
practical effect this is a deterrent no
coach or manager or general manager if
he knows about it is going to let this
go on and run the risk to his career
talking to Bob Costas what do you think
happens with the Red Sox you know I'm a
little vague on that I don't know of
course it is Quora
related going back to Houston and then
compounded by whatever might have
happened with the Red Sox but the few
Red Sox who have commented JD Martinez
and and Keith Moreland have said not
Keith Moore when I'm clinging back to
the old Cubs I got my Moreland confused
some of the West Coast and early in the
morning anyway Mitch Moreland Mitch
Moreland bait they have kind of flatly
said we're not aware of anything that
went on we don't expect that we as a
team are going to be hit all that hard
but we'll see within a week they say
that the decision will be rendered by
the end of next week
well won't be the players because they
can't get punished right right but they
were they were saying we weren't aware
of anything going on at all
they can't be punished but if you were
aware that something was going on you
would think you wouldn't walk out on the
limb that way and say nothing to see
here but we'll find out and last time
you Ron you were talking about expanding
the playoffs or you wanted to clarify
something you said last time you were on
yeah baseball has floated an idea about
expanding the playoffs or you'd have the
three division winners and the best
division winner would get a bye and then
you would have four wildcards and I said
to you but I thought that some of this
had merit and was worth discussing I
don't have any problem with a television
show as a selection show it's an idea
Colet the higher
teams pick their opponents there might
be some strategy involved there but it
was made to seem not by you but by some
people as if I was promoting this idea
or that I was all-in and what I actually
said was this is a starting point and
there's lots of ways that you could come
at it and the one thing that you have to
be mindful of and I've always said this
going back to when they added the first
wild card is the difference between
baseball and other sports the difference
between the history of a pennant race
and mere playoff qualifying and of
course the difference in the length of
the season the NFL goes and expands as
we just talked about their seasons the
10th is long roughly as baseball's
season so you can't I don't think you
can throw division winners last year for
example in the American League three
teams won more than a hundred games it's
one thing to say the two wildcards have
to play a one game knockout or a best
two out of three if you come in through
the side door that makes sense or if you
play a whole season and you wind up at a
dead heat Giants and Dodgers played two
out of three and fifty-one the Bucky
Dent game the Yankees and Red Sox played
a single game but that makes sense
because they played to a dead heat
over 150 for 162 but if you play 162
games or wherever they wind up 156 and
one team wins a hundred and the other is
the fourth wildcard and has a 500 record
then a best two out of three might not
be an acceptable crapshoot think of how
often this is baseball not basketball a
football think of how often a team that
wins 90 plus games loses two out of
three at home during the course of the
season to a team that finishes under 500
because it's baseball so I don't think
that what they've thrown out there is
interesting and has some merit but
they've got to reconcile it with the
validity of the long season so if you
have two more minutes here I would say
where they are now just with the five
playoff qualifiers and two wildcards
relieved
they could make the wild-card round best
two out of three with all three on the
home field of the better wild-card
qualifier that makes sense and they
could make the Division Series best out
of seven instead of best out of
that also makes competitive sense and
they'd only have to cut the season back
to 156 which is one three-game home
series for each team in order for the
World Series not to push into November
or if they wanted to add one wildcard in
the present setup they could give
first-round byes to the two highest
playoff qualifiers who have less of a
chance of an extreme inequity there or
if and when they go to 32 teams which is
going to happen somewhere down the road
then you could reconfigure into 218
divisions per league arranged
geographically then logically completely
logically the two division winners get a
bye and you have four wild-card teams
per league and and there you wind up
with something that's expanded it's
modernized but it still respects the
importance of the long baseball season
you feel better I feel so much I don't
take you $75 for the hour on I'm here
for you Bob I'm here thank you Bob
you're welcome dad thanks to Bob Costas
Hall of Fame broadcaster for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]